Olá pessoal tudo bem sabe aquele remédio
que tomamos automaticamente para aliviar
dor de cabeça ou dor nas costas ele pode
estar afetando silenciosamente um órgão
essencial pra nossa saúde que é o fígado
Você já parou para pensar sobre a
importância de conhecer quais
medicamentos podem prejudicar o fígado a
realidade é preocupante mas essencial
estarmos informados em nosso mundo
moderno o fígado já enfrenta desafios
diários sendo sobrecarregado e lutando
contra várias toxinas ambientais entre
elas resíduos de agrotóxicos metais
pesados alimentos Ultra processadas e
até poluição todos esses são Inimigos da
saúde do fígado agora imagine somar a
essa carga já elevada que intoxica o
nosso fígado o impacto de medicamentos
que podem causar danos hepáticos ainda
mais severos tanto de forma aguda quanto
crônica é uma realidade que não podemos
simplesmente ignorar saber quais são
esses medicamentos e como eles afetam o
fígado é muito importante se a medicação
for indispensável precisamos repensar e
adaptar outros aspectos na nossa vida
como a dieta e hábitos para proteger e
fortalecer nosso fígado Este é um
assunto sério que exige Nossa Total
atenção e cuidado eu quero fazer uma
Alerta importante se você já está
tomando algum medicamento prescrito por
um médico Não Pare de usar por conta
própria a interrupção repentina pode ser
prejudicial e cont producente é
essencial que você tenha uma conversa
aberta e honesta com seu médico se
estiver preocupado com o impacto que o
medicamento pode estar tendo no seu
fígado pode ser necessário ajustar a
medicação ou adotar uma abordagem
diferente para resolver o problema e se
você é uma pessoa que se automedica esse
vídeo é um alerta especial para você
além disso se você está experimentando
sintomas que podem indicar problemas do
fígado como fadiga comum amarelamento da
pele ou dos olhos urina escura fezes
pálidas ou dor abdominal procure
imediatamente atendimento médico pessoal
não subestime esses sinais a saúde
hepática é delicada e complexa e merece
a nossa atenção e cuidado constantes Mas
por que certas medicações podem
sobrecarregar esse órgão tão Vital o
fígado é o principal local de
metabolização de medicamentos em nosso
corpo Isso significa que ele trabalha
arduamente para quebrar essas medica
transformá-las em substâncias que nosso
corpo pode usar ou excretar com
segurança quando tomamos certas
medicações especialmente em doses altas
ou por períodos prolongados podemos
aumentar a carga de trabalho do fígado
algumas medicações são realmente muito
difíceis pro nosso fígado trabalhar isso
pode levar a inflamação e Danos
hepáticos afetando a eficiência com que
ele Realiza suas funções básicas e você
é novo por aqui clique em inscrever e
entre pra nossa turma saudável e se você
curtiu o vídeo dê um joinha Não guarde
ess informações e dicas só para você
compartilhe com seus amigos e familiares
no WhatsApp e outras redes sociais
espare saúde e informação de qualidade
Então vamos à lista vou começar com uma
medicação bastante conhecida os
antibióticos eles são importante grupo
de medicamentos utilizados para combater
infecções bacterianas no entanto
utilizá-los de forma de equivocada ou
errada é uma das principais causas da
onda de super bactérias existentes pelo
mundo mas Além disso existe também o
risco pro fígado falando por exemplo da
mxic silina mais clavulanato que é uma
combinação amplamente utilizada para
tratar infecções bacterianas como
infecções de garganta pneumonia
infecções do trato urinário ou sinusite
e por acaso você provavelmente já usou
esse medicamento muitas pessoas já
utilizaram e essa combinação Amoxicilina
com clavulanato está entos medicamentos
mais Associados a danos hepáticos essa
combinação engloba um antibiótico e um
composto que impede a resistência
bacteriana ao mesmo acredita-se que os
danos hepáticos ocorram devido a uma
reação alérgica interna embora o
mecanismo exato ainda não seja bem
conhecido outros medicamentos
antibióticos frequentemente relacionados
à lesões hepáticas incluem a isoniazida
trimetropin sulfametoxazol
eritromicina nitrofurantoina e
minociclina
mas atenção Nunca Pare de usar o
antibiótico sem conversar com o seu
médico antes isso é muito perigoso
pessoal e as famosas estatinas
amplamente usadas no tratamento de
colesterol alto e na prevenção de
eventos
cardiovasculares elas podem causar um
aumento nas enzimas hepáticas que
sinalizam danos ao fígado embora esse
dano seja mais raro cerca de 5% dos
pacientes podem ter essa alteração se
esse aumento for leve geralmente é
seguro continuar com a medicação no
entanto um aumento grve ave pode exigir
a troca de medicação não podemos
esquecer que as estatinas podem levar a
efeitos colaterais diversos como dores
musculares e um risco aumentado diabetes
tipo do Além disso alguns pacientes
podem experimentar problemas
neurológicos como confusão e PDA de
memória prosseguindo com as medicações
que causam
hepatotoxicidade temos os famosos
anticoncepcionais orais eles contêm
estrogênio e progestina que são
metabolizados pelo fígado e esse
processo alização pode levar alterações
nas enzimas hepáticas e eventualmente
danos ao fígado especialmente com uso
prolongado um dos principais riscos
associados ao uso de
anticoncepcionais é o aumento de risco
de eventos tromboembólicos as tromboses
trombose venose profunda e embolia
pulmonar esses Eventos São relacionados
ao aumento da produção dos fatores de
coagulação no fígado e adesão
plaquetária Além disso certas condições
hepáticas como Hepatite viral neoplasia
hepática e cirrose também são
consideradas contraindicações para uso
de anticoncepcionais orais então fiquem
alertas e Conversem com os médicos
pessoal a metildopa que é usada para
tratamento de pressão alta hipertensão
arterial pode causar danos ao fígado
como eu já expliquei o fígado desempenha
um papel fundamental na metabolização de
vários medicamentos incluindo a
metildopa em alguns indivíduos essa
metabolização pode ser mais lenta
aumentando o risco de danos hepáticos
além dis disso doses elevadas de
qualquer medicamento poem danificar um
fígado mesmo Saudável em alguns casos a
metildopa foi associada a icterícia que
é olho amarelo e alterações e exames de
função hepática compatíveis com
colestase que é quando o fluxo de bile
produzido pelo fígado é prejudicado
obstruído portanto recomenda-se
monitoramento cuidadoso da função
hepática durante o tratamento com esse
medicamento metildopa agora atenção
pessoal vamos vamos falar sobre os
antiinflamatórios não esteroidais os
famosos
Anes que são esses antiinflamatórios
comuns de farmácia de clofenac
iboprofeno Nimesulida e Naproxeno eu sei
que muitos de vocês recorrem esses
remédios para aliviar dores e
inflamações mas eu preciso alertar eles
não são tão inofensivos quanto parece o
uso indiscriminado desses medicamentos
pode ser uma armadilha pro seu fígado
vamos entender ao metabolizar esses
remédios o fígado pode criar sub subas
tóxicas danificando suas próprias
células e não para por aí o uso
prolongado antiinflamatório está
associado a problemas graves como
úlceras do estômago hemorragia é um
risco real Especialmente para quem já
tem problemas de saúde ou toma outros
medicamentos é que vai uma bronca bem
tensionada usar medicamentos
antiinflamatórios para dores sem
supervisão médica é um risco que você
não deve correr se tem o hábito de
recorrer esse medicamentos
frequentemente é hora hora de repensar
consultem o médico para uma avaliação
adequada e para monitorar a saúde do
fígado e lembrem-se em caso de doenças
hepáticas ou renais os antiinflamatórios
podem ser verdadeiros vilões pessoal out
outro medicamento que pode ter
consequências perigosas pro nosso fígado
é o
metotrexato é um medicamento utilizado
num tratamento de certos tipos de câncer
doenças autoimunes e Artrite reumatoide
o metotrexate ou metotrexato pode causar
danos ao fígado devido ao seu
metabolismo hepático complicado e a sua
capacidade de induzir stresse oxidativo
e inflamação no tecido hepático Além
disso O metotrexato pode interferir na
via de metilação do fígado e na produção
de certos aminoácidos o que pode
contribuir para a toxicidade hepática
fique atentos converse com o seu médico
a nossa comunidade de membros que tira
dúvidas comigo diretamente em lives
exclusivas semanais já aprendeu muito
sobre saúde conheça esse outros
benefícios clica no botão abaixo seja
membro pessoal atenção ao uso de
antifungicos infelizmente temos uma
epidemia de doenças fúngicas com micose
candidíase e muitas vezes essas
medicações são importantes mas existem
problemas e perigos a serem considerados
por exemplo o antifungico cetaconazol
ele foi por muito tempo a principal
escolha para tratamento de micoses após
ser ingerido ele é rapidamente absorvido
e distribuído pelo corpo sendo então
processado de forma principal pelo
fígado no entanto descobriu-se que o
Cetoconazol pode causar toxicidade
hepática E colestase especialmente
mulheres acima de 40 anos por essa razão
desde 2013 órgãos reguladores como fda
americano e Anvisa brasileira recomendam
cautela no uso desse medicamento devido
ao risco pro fígado e não é só o
cetoconazol que merece a nossa atenção o
Fluconazol outro antifungo Popular
também é conhecido por sua
hepatotoxicidade ele pode ser
particularmente perigoso pro fígado
sendo desaconselhado para pessoas com
problemas de fígado ou com o sistema
imunológico debilitado é essencial que
tenhamos consciência desses riscos
existem soluções naturais interessantes
que são alternativas para combater as
infecções causadas por fungos agora
vamos falar sobre um medicamento muito
com com um e ao mesmo tempo um grande
vilão pro fígado o paracetamol a
toxicidade do paracetamol é uma causa
comum de insuficiência hepática aguda
especialmente em crianças e adolescentes
pessoal só que o paracetamol é na
verdade a principal causa de
insuficiência hepática induzida por
medicamentos é o número um de problemas
esse remédio facilmente encontrado em
farmácia Supermercado é um ingrediente
muito comum muito presente em
medicamentos para gripe resfriados ele é
conhecido por muitos como alívio rápido
para dores e febres o maior problema é
que muitos medicamentos trazem
paracetamol na composição junto de
outras substâncias com isso uma pessoa
que está gripada ou resfriada por
exemplo acaba ingerindo diversos
fármacos para lidar com sintomas que é
dor febre nariz estupida etc e pode
acabar utilizando uma dose maior e bem
problemática do medicamento além do
fígado metabolizar o fármaco cerca de 5%
do remédio se transforma em
quinoneimina que é uma substância tóxica
pro corpo em pequenas quantidades o
fígado consegue neutralizar o perigo
Porém quando há uma quantidade grande de
Quin nemina o órgão entra em parafuso e
deixe de funcionar como esperado isso
por sua vez gera um quadro de falência
hepática aguda que não raro demanda
internação em transplante Além de estar
relacionado ao risco aumentado de morte
pessoas com doenças hepáticas
preexistentes ou que consomem álcool de
maneira contínua estão em maior risco de
desenvolver
hepatotoxicidade com o uso de
paracetamol Isso significa que mesmo que
pareça seguro o uso desse medicamento
requer muita cautela e atenção em
qualquer dose algumas outras substâncias
que podem causar danos ao fígado são os
anabolizantes além de medicamentos como
tiazolidinedionas
tocona amiodarona antidepressivos
tricíclicos
fluoroquinolonas tetraciclinas
isoniazida rifampicina aloto valproato
de sódio fenitoína e oxifen isatina em
alguns casos o Roacutan um medicamento
utilizado para tratamento da acne das
espinhas de rosto Severa podem causar
hepatite medicamentosa mas que desparece
com a diminuição da dose ou com a
suspensão é importante ressaltar que os
danos ao fígado não corre em todos os
pacientes que tomam Esses medicamentos
mas toda a atenção é primordial e
lembre-se Se tiverem dúvidas ou
condições de saúde específicas consultem
o médico a sua saúde hepática é preciosa
e merece cuidado e atenção continuem
comigo não sai daí assiste esses dois
vídeos relacionados são bem
interessantes o primeiro deles é oito
comidas que destrói o seu fígado e o
outro é 15 sinais na pele que revelam
problemas do fígado estão aparecendo aí
na sua tela bem pessoal
muito obrigado de coração pela sua
atenção um grande abraço um beijo no seu
coração você é
feira